all right let's start
welcome to the ddps seminar today before
we introduce to this speaker
let's go over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless
it is urgent so that our speaker can
talk without unnecessary interruptions
that way we all can enjoy and focus on
the talk
second no classified discussion
is allowed finally the talk today will
be recorded
so if you have questions it is
encouraged to use the chat room but if
you
like to address the question right away
you can unmute yourself
and ask questions all right um
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker
uh i'm very honored to host today's
speaker professor alfio cuatroni
he was he is professor emeritus
at epfl um at switzerland
and now he's also a professor in
numerical analysis department at the
politik di milano in italy
he is the author of 25 books editor of
12 books
author of about 400 papers and
editor-in-chief
of two book series published by springer
he is the recipient of numerous prizes
from oiler price in 2015 to galileo
galilei international prize
for mathematics in 2015 and many more
he is also a member of well-known
organizations such as the italian
academy of science
member of academia european
member of the lisbon academy of science
fellow of the european academy of
sciences and zion fellow
and many more and his research interest
focuses on mathematical modeling
numerical analysis scientific computing
with application to fluid mechanics
geophysics medicine and the improvement
of sports
performance his research for example has
carried
out the mathematical simulation for the
optimization
of performance of the elingy yacht
the winner of two editions in 2003 and
of the americas cup today
we present the mathematical heart
a computational model for the simulation
of the heart function
now let me pass the button to professor
quateroni
out here it's all yours thank you very
much
i i am facing a little problem i'm
really sorry i
i can't see uh the presentation anymore
so
please be patient for one minute i try
to rejoin the meeting
really sorry oh no problem okay go ahead
let me see if i can
one meeting in progress so what should i
do here
uh
really sorry for that so good morning
uh it's evening here in europe in europe
but
it's this morning on the west coast um
so thanks very much for this invitation
and uh this is the title of my talk
and uh uh as you see it has to see with
the uh
uh a mathematical and a numerical model
for
uh for the heart actually uh to simulate
the heart function
uh so i'd like to start by by by
acknowledging the contribution of many
uh
junior and and senior people senior
collaborators almost all of them from
milano
and uh i'd also like to thank uh
the collaboration from many uh medical
doctors
from different hospitals and different
countries um
of course this is a teamwork um
let me just say very few words about our
physiology
i think you all know what is the heart
uh you know that the heart has
four chambers two a a3 and two
ventricles it
receives the blood the venous blood
from the uh vena cava inferior
and superior vena cava and it ejects
blood
into the aorta the ascending orta and
enriches
all the billions of cells that are
making our bodies say
there is one effect
which is the one of the mechanical pump
it is a mechanical pump actually
with uh compress and and and relaxes
it compresses in the so-called diastolic
phase
it relaxes in sorry in the historic
and it will access in the diastolic
phase um
the venus blood is sent to the lungs
for releasing the co2
and absorbing uh oxygen and then it gets
back
to the upper part
of of the heart of course
the heart beats because uh because there
is the electrical field
which is activating that they are
beating and uh
there is a sparkling um effect that is
originating to the
sinoatrial node in the upper part of the
right atrium and then an electrical
field is generated it propagates
through the upper part of the of the
heart and the two atria and then it
reaches this new node which is
uh the um atrioventricular node and
and from there through a very
sophisticated set
of uh of um network say
it reaches all the cells of our
myocardium
so the idea here is to try to simulate
all these processes so the
electrical process the mechanical
process of contractual deformation
the fluid dynamical process because
there is blood
inside the chambers and then the opening
and closing of the valves
and and of course the connection with
the external circulation
so this is the idea this is the agenda
say and
as you know i will not insist on that
but as you know when you want to go to
the numerical simulation
you actually need to create a
geometric model and then a mesh
or a grid say now the geometrical model
you can get it from real patients
using ct scan or mri or you can take it
from atlas
or you can take from cad solid models
like the one that you see here in the
middle
the the zygote called zygote sorry 3d
heart human human heart
now here is the reproduction so the
solid model
and you see in particular the grid in
the myocardium
this is just a detail of the grid in the
myocardium
this is the finest grid that we'll be
using we use a 60 million of exatra
in the myocardium and and this grid will
be useful to simulate
the electrophysiology in particular the
electrical
propagation uh in the myocardium as well
as the deformation of the myocardium
we need however a second grid which is
the one that you use in uh
in the ventricles and in the atria and
and this is the one that we'll be using
for simulating the fluid dynamical
processes
so this is just a preview of what we'll
be using later on
so the very first step when we try to
face
this issue of creating a global heart
model
is to go and deal with the single
we call them core cardiac modems and
they include the electrophysiology the
active mechanics
at the cell level the passive mechanics
at the organ level the fluid dynamics
the vast motion and the perfusion of the
myocardium
through the coronaries so let me start
with electrophysiology model
of course we have no time to derive the
model here
but if you are interested of course
there are plenty of
references we also wrote a book a couple
of years ago with cambridge university
press
on on model in the heart but let me just
go to the equations and then do the same
also for the other um core models
so the the equation of the electrical
propagation is based on either the
mono-domain equation
or the by-domain equation the more
domain is simpler
is the one that you see reported here
and it's
you see a partial differential equation
that depends on
space and time it's
say an elliptic equation with
a reaction term which is an online
reaction term
so in the elliptic component you have u
which is
the transmembrane potential the
difference between
the um the the the potential
uh at the extra potential the inter
potential in the
in the cells and then you have the
anesthetic which accounts for the ionic
activity
[Music]
the ionic activity is described by this
set of
order differential equations so u is the
transmembrane for the egg potential
w is the set of the only variables this
is a conductivity
tensor that will play a very important
role because it of course it
accounts for the heterogeneity of the
muscular structure the structure of the
myocardium
and then you end the transmembrane
capacitance uh
you have the external applied current
and so on and so forth
now there are many different models that
can be used
to describe the ionic activity here are
some
important names say the arif panphilov
the curtimage
um that the the fabian severity the
tentacle palm pilot
that we'll be using for the atria
otherwise we have the bueno rovio
the tormentor ligo sohera rudi or the
bartolucci passing severity
for the ventricles so these models very
often
are experimental models are
phenomenological models
and and of course they have to be tuned
to the specific application that you
have in mind
now at the cell level at every heartbeat
so
a heartbeat takes place over
say one second or less than one second
this of course depends on individuals
um as this typical structure so the
potential
which is called the action potential uh
moves from a resting phase
to a short repolarization and then
sorry to a depolarization which is
followed by a short phase of
of repolarization then there is a kind
of flat area which is called the plateau
and then the complete repolarization and
it goes back to the resting phase
and and this occurs for the first 400
milliseconds
about half of of the heartbeat
and what we see here are uh is the
membrane is the membrane of the cell
and you see the channels that open and
close and they allow the ions to move
forward and backward and this is what
creates the
the difference in the potential say um
this is just one simulation you see um
one heart which is based on the zygote
cad model and here you see the um
the potential that propagates you see
two different views
the left one is from the uh pericardium
which is the external surface of the
heart and and the right one
is a a cross-sectional view say
here you have a mini volt you typically
go from minus 82
to to say 40. so
this is the solution of the previous
electrophysiology problems one example
and this is basically the same solution
but you have a different vision
sorry different view you see on the left
the activation map and you see the time
at which
every single say cell in the myocardium
has been activated electrically
on the right hand side you see the
activation front
that propagates from the sine nitral
node to the atria first and then down to
the ventricles
of course you can use this type of
simulation for clinical applications
it is just one snapshot we are trying to
consider here a heart that is affected
by
a problem of rhythm you have a
ventricular arrhythmia
which is a kind of irregular propagation
of the electric potential in the heart
and one important issue here is to
identify
what are called in the clinical practice
biomarkers
and these are line sorry lines of
silicon
areas of low conduction there are
lines of blocks there are
zones of late activation and it's
important to try to
identify those kind of pathological
biomarkers
because once you have them identified
then
doctors arithmologists can try to
operate
what they call an ablation so they just
burn
specific points in order to restore
hopefully a healthy and physiological
rhythm
now here mathematics can help numerical
simulation can help
trying to identify by numerical
simulation
uh this very complex pattern
of uh of uh of electrical propagation
and those specific points and try to
suggest
the doctors where to ablate and ideally
to solve
an optimal design problem find the
optimal places in order to
say optimize the time of ablation
and also the and those optimizing the
efficiency of ablation
of course this is work in progress but i
think there is plenty of room for uh
for for great great improvement and to
to
to show that this is really very very
very effective type of uh
help that you can provide the doctors
now if you try to set up a mathematical
model you have to face
the issue of the data and data are the
geometrical data
i mentioned that before when it say that
you have to reconstruct the geometry and
of course to create the grid
but there are also many other data which
are i mean characterizing the specific
card
um one of those datas are for the data
are the fibers the distribution of the
fibers
and and the collagen sheets
now the fibers the muscle fibers are
very important in the model because they
enter at two
different sites first of all
they are very useful to characterize the
conductivity tensor
in the model domain or the by domain
model
the one that allowed to reconstruct the
propagating
potential and the second one is that
when you solve the mechanical problem
you want to compute
the deformation of the heart well you
will end up with
typically a lagrangian representation of
the displacement
and and and then you need to introduce
and i will come back to that uh the uh
in particular the biology chef and the
priority hf will depend
on the fiber distribution so
reconstructing the fibers is very
important
and typically fibers are not really
ready to be used how can you get them
you can get them
by imaging techniques like the tmri
diffusion tensor mri well first of all
they are not really
available in the clinical practice every
day in all possible hospitals
and the intake indiana are very noisy
you can get them from atlas of course
those are not patient-specific
but you need a very complex vegetation
algorithms or you can use a purely based
numerical method it's called rule-based
numerical method
right and and you compute kind of
surrogate myofibers
and let me say a couple of words on that
rule-based methods exploit information
from
histology or from diffusion tensor and
right
observations they compute potentials
two type of potentials the first one is
associated with the transmittal distance
and the second one is called the normal
distance which is indeed the apex to
base distance
so you solve basically as you see
laplace equations
to compute those potentials thanks to
those laplace equations
you can introduce a new frame of
reference
and this framework reference is the one
that is along with the fibers
with the normal duration of the fibers
and and and the sheath
which are the collagen sheet by rotating
the axis
when you have this type of solution here
you see the way you proceed
you first of all first of all you have
to level uh the different
components of the heart the different
surfaces
then you compute the transmittal
distance by solving those
um say elliptic equations you compute
the normal distance
you compute the gradient and then you
introduce the local coordinate
and you end up hopefully with the fibers
you see them here
on the left hand side and you see them
on the right hand side
so this is a kind of pre-processing in
order to recompute in order to
say obtain the fibrous distribution
this is done for the two atria
together this is the first time as far
as we know that this has been
done for the two later together and then
and then we patch them with the two
ventricles
and you end up with the global
reconstruction of the fibers what you
see here is
the posterior view and then an anterior
view
and you see different colors you often
read which refer to the fiber
distribution of the
epicardium the epicardium is the
external surface
of the heart and then you have the blue
which is the endocardium
and of course translucently you have a
variation of those fibers
so these are preliminary computation and
in order to fit both the
electrophysiology model
and the mechanical model now let me say
few words on the mechanical model
we use the classical lagrangian
formulation so we introduce the
displacement from a reference
configuration
this is a kind of idealized ventricle to
a curl configuration
we introduce the displacement we
introduce the deformation tensor
f we introduce the pure acute stress
tensor
which is the derivative of a strain
energy function
with respect to the deformation tensor
and of course you have to make
assumptions on the nature of the of the
of the tissue
so we're assuming here that the material
is hyperelastic
um so the the the passive elastic
passive elastic properties depend
on a strain energy function and and and
it's incompressible
because it's mainly uh or mostly say
composed of
waters or blood say so it's indeed
a very similar to a fluid in terms of
behavior
and here i will not have the time to
elaborate on that but we use two
different
straight energies one is the glutoni
liquid
energy uh and the other is the oldapan
and doctor
energy and we'll be using both of them
then the point is that you have to see
how to generate the active force so what
is the active force
the active force is the one that is
generated at the
mile cell level the cardio filament
myocardial filament
right and that you have to assume that
to be say
similar to a uni
dimensional object and of course you
want to produce the force
that is you to you want to compute the
force that is due to the presence of the
electrical field
and this force will allow this
cardiomyofilament to stretch
and to relax so you have different type
of models to do that
uh one is based on the so-called active
stress
the other one is based on the collective
strain and and and the amount to
to use a different type of splitting of
the deformation
uh gradient say
so you have the state variables that
describe
according to different models uh the
status
of the cardomy filament and then
once you have computed those state
variables
you feed the passive mechanics component
of of the elastic model say here you use
the classical
elastodynamics equations where you have
the second derivative in time of the
displacement
you have the divergence of the of the
pure accuracy of stress
and you have non-trivial non i would say
canonical boundary conditions on the
surfaces
and the other surfaces are the
epicardium the external
external surface the endocardium which
is the internal surface
and then you have this basal surface
which is the upper surface in this
ventricle
so this is the mechanical model which
accounts for both
the active and so-called say passive
component
and now you want to couple together the
active and passive mechanics
with the electrical potential
propagation with the ionic activity at
the cell level
and with the mechanical activation of
the cardiomyofilament
so this is a couple system and every
block here is coupled to
the other blocks and they exchange
important information so the acting
passive mechanics
passes strains to the electrical
potential propagation
this one communicates with the ionic
activity
uh by exchanging the potential and
receiving the ionic current
the ionic activity the model for the
ionic activity passes the calcium
concentration
to the mechanical activation and this
passes say the active stress
to the active passive mechanics and
since here you are deforming
the the the solid part you are changing
the geometry
and you have to update the new geometry
when you consider the mechanical
activation so as you can guess
those are non-linear problems and and
and they're fully coupled
now this is the global model when you
have the electrophysiology activation
the mechanics all together
and what you see here are just snapshots
from the solution
you see the activation time you see the
electric potential at a given time
and you see the displacement again at a
given time
so um the the point is that
heart is not isolated from the rest of
the body from the retrocirculation
so how do i account for the rest of
circulation here you have many different
possibilities one possibility would be
to use
say brute force using fluid dynamics
based on navistox separation
on the old external circulation which is
barely impossible you have billions of
small capillaries
and hundreds of large arteries just to
to to to to say what you have to be
uh what what you have to face so
typically use reuse models
and this is one of those that we we are
actually using
and this is a zero dimensional model
zero d means that there is no space
dimension every every any longer
we only have systems of all the
differential equations
so you have a block of equations that
describe
the volumes the change of volumes
initial ventricles
then a block of equations that describe
the change of pressures
the natural ventricle systemic and
polymer circulation
and then another one that described the
fluoride and then of course you have to
couple them
with the three-dimensional model that
we've seen before
so um this is a critical issue
indeed you have to find the proper
interface conditions
in order to be as conservative as
possible
say because i mean this is a whole
system and they're just
for computational convenience splitting
it into two components
one which is described by
three-dimensional model and and the
other one is described by
a system of all the differential
equations
so this is just an example of a heart
deformation
you have the two ventricles and and here
they are
contracting and relaxing and that to get
this simulation we have to solve
the electro mechanical uh coupled
model that that we have seen uh before
uh doing the same type of simulation now
you have two ventricles what you see
here what you can appreciate here
is the contraction of the fibers along
the heartbeat
and also on the right a picture you also
see
the calcium concentration the way it
changes
on the myocardium and this is the effect
of the solution of the problem
at the cell's level and now you have the
fluid dynamics
for dynamics you you are solving the
problem in the
in the chambers so in the ventricle for
example the left ventricle or in the
on the atria say and and here you solve
the navistox equations
uh the incompressible uh viscous
navistox equations
in ali formulation what what what is ale
this stands for arbitrary lagrangian
eulerian formulation why that because
we solve typically free dynamical
problem in an eulerian framework
and and and the solid mechanics in a
lagrangian framework so you have to
accommodate the two frameworks and one
possibility
is to use this arbitrary lagrangiolarian
uh this amounts to use the classical
continuity equation the versions of u
equal to zero for another stokes
and you have to slightly modify
the momentum equation uh instead of
computing the classical eulerian
time derivative of the velocity namely
the acceleration term
you compute the ale derivative on on a
reference domain basically
that is used to retrieve at any time the
actual domain which is not the
lagrangian domain because there are
regions
like this one that are fixed right
that are prescribed a priori so this
really a kind of
hybrid representation and you have to
modify the convective velocity by
subtracting the
rate of deformation of of the grid
so this is called the ai velocity you
need a
second equation which
is there to compute the way the volume
deform
uh every point in the volume in the
lumen the form
according depending upon the deformation
of the surface which is the deformation
of the myocardium so we are using here
an harmonic extension
and and and of course you have
to to adopt this type of say uh
to slack lightly modify the navy stocks
equation in order to allow for
the computation in a domain that is
moving
here is an example simulation this is
the left atrium
you see on the left the the modulus of
the velocity field
and on the right you see um
the vorticity actually this is uh plot
according to the q criterium that i will
uh use
also later on so you see in a in a
physiological heart the way
the the big vortices are created
from the four
pulmonary veins that that bring
oxygenated blood
from the the lungs and
and then you see the way the the the
vortices are
dissipated um now
we have valves and we have to simulate
the behavior of valves
and there are many different ways you
can go again
by say very simple models that are based
on uh
just algebraic model to move
the valves without any fine description
of center we just move the geometry
up to three-dimensional model structural
mechanics
for the valves or some intermediate
approaches
that are more affordable from the
computational point of view and also
reasonably reasonably
acceptable uh if if you if you deal with
the stimulation of the fluid if you
don't necessarily deal with
the computational stresses within the
valves
so this is a kind of immersed approach
we're using the so-called
riis method which is the resistive
immersed implicit surface
this amounts to perturb the momentum
equation of the stokes
by an extra third and this extra turn uh
uh
accounts for the um motion of the valves
actually for the velocity of motion of
the valves
and and you have turns that that account
for
as you see here the inverse surface
of the valve themselves a resistance
coefficient that you have to tune
um then the thickness of the valves as a
direct function a direct delta function
you want that this say source term with
only operate
on on the on the um on the space
occupied by the valve
uh and so you need that to introduce
this direct function that is
distributed on the bar themselves and of
course you have to
to to smooth it in order to treat it
numerically
so this is the modification
uh on the fruit part that we
introduce in order to compute
the action of the valves and this is
just one example
what you see here is the aortic valve is
the one that separates
the left ventricle from the ascending
aorta
is a three lifted valves and the three
leaflets open
and close i would say almost
instantaneously
so there is very fast dynamics and this
is one of the reason why
eventually you'll be forced to use time
step that will be very very time if you
want really to
to follow the dynamics of what's going
to happen
now this is a
computational free dynamics model that
is
coupled with a zero dimensional mode
also for the
uh say the cfd model we have to couple
it with external circulation
so this is another uh possible model
that we
we have to use and again i'm not
uh elaborate on that because of the of
the of the of the
time uh constraint but as you can guess
what is also very critical is the way
you actually
match the 3d model with the 0d model and
basically what we do is reportedly on
the right
the zero dimensional pressures are
healed are passed to the
to the three-dimensional model and they
healed the 3d normal cause stress tensor
which provides basically a normal
boundary condition for the
two-dimensional model
and on this term the three-dimensional
model
you compute the rate of volume variation
of the cardiac chambers
and and those information provide the
zero d
the flow rate for the zero demanded say
both are
in inverting the type of interface
condition that you have to
to that we actually use for for uh
accommodating the coupling
um of the 3d with the 0d say
so here is one example where we have
this three-dimensional model
coupled with the zero dimensional model
in action uh this is the left part of
the
of the heart and you see in the upper
part
the atrium and the lower part the
ventricle and here you see the
ascending ortho here is
are the isocontous of the q criterion a
q
is as you see in the formula on the left
is
one half the square of the
norm of uh the rotation tensor minus the
square the norm
of the strain rate tensors so this is
one heartbeat
on the left uh on the left heart
um now uh here
is the way we uh couple
the fluid dynamics and the structural
mechanics
um so we have fluid dynamics
equations again based on the aale
approach
then we have the structural mechanics
which is the electrodynamics system that
i've introduced before
then you have the harmonic extension and
of course you have the coupling
condition
this is the adherence condition this one
is the kinematic condition and this one
is the dynamic condition for the
equilibration resources
so um what is missing is the myocardium
perfusion model and then our model will
be
basically complete now cardiac diffusion
means that
the myocardium itself needs blood
needs to be nurtured by blood
and it takes blood from the coronaries
and now you have the big coordinates
on the epicardium side these are called
the epicardium-based epicardial vessel
the epicardial coronaries
but then you have say
a tens of thousands of small
vessels uh in
the transportal myocardium
and how do we set up a model
to describe the flow field in this
very complex setting we basically use a
multi-scale approach
we use a navistox equation three dynamic
stokes equations on the epicardial
vessels
and then we use a three compartment.c
model
say porous meter description for the
myocardium and we have three different
levels
of of
size of corners in the myocardium
and uh we generate a surrogate
interbureal vascular network
uh based on some optimized energy
principle
and we end up with
as you see the use of navistox equations
in the external
uh on the epicardium vessels and then
three different
vessel uh compartment which coexist in
the same environment right
so at every single point you can or the
myocardium can identify
in the model the presence of the large
vessels the medium bases and the small
vessel
so there's a kind of homogenization
mathematical homogenization principle
and and this is a global system for the
perfusion then you have the navi stores
and then you have the multi-compartment
darcy approximation
and then your interface condition same
so this is the last
model and this is the first clinical
validation
we see nine different patients p1 p2
pep9 and for each of them you see their
own
its own reconstruction of the
epicardium vessels and then you see the
comparison between
the measured perfusion map
which is obtained using a ct stress
machine
so it's a is a stress test on the
patient of course
and that is he here you find
the computed perfusion map and the
comparison is quite good for
all those cases uh the error is
below one percent on all the nine
patients say
um and this is quite reassuring because
this test
is quite demanding i mean you have to
um to to give to patient uh to infuse
the patient with uh
that with a toxic uh drug as as
very often happens unfortunately and uh
and of course for some patients this
test can be particularly stressful and
even even sometimes dangerous
so here the hope is to try to use
numerical simulation to uh
to to replace the test uh of course is a
dream but
you have to start with a dream and then
start with first failures and then with
the first success
and then hopefully to improve the final
step
so this is a big monster uh this is the
old cardiac function
model you see all these components here
you see the active and passive mechanics
which is really acting as
the driving factor of the old heart
uh functioning and then you see the
perfusion the mechanical activation the
electrophysiology
the meteorologist the ortho valve
dynamics and the connection with the
rest of the circulation
and of course you have the connectors
the connectors are the interface
conditions
namely the way all these blocks is
changed information
physical information one with the others
and
and and this is what we can call the
integrated heart mode
so should we be able to solve this model
we will be able to to have
the say a simulation of the whole our
function
so let me just mention some of the um
main challenges here from the numerical
viewpoint
we have multiple scales we have seen
them we have lack of data
we miss initial conditions boundary
conditions coefficients fibers
we need geometrical nonconformities so
we typically generate grades
in an independent way for the different
uh
parts of the of the heart for the lumen
for that for the
for the muscle for the for the for the
valves
so you need non-conforming methods to
accommodate all those grid
uh we will use splitting algorithms you
we cannot afford using a monolithic
method to solve all this
say model in a in a single shot
um we need scalable preconditions
because
all the systems are stiff and the chords
are big
not in algebraic systems um we need to
use modal order reduction
because often uh if you if you pretend
being uh
say cooperating with doctors we have to
provide
solutions if not in real time in a
reasonable time so
not not to unreasonable at least so you
have to use
extensively moderate reduction
approaches and and you have to account
for variability and uncertainty
um those are the major issues so we we
have realized there was still in the
process realizing a library
a scientific library which sits on on
the deal d2
uh finite element backhand library and
this implements all the cardiac models
all the numerical approximation and all
the algorithms and we call this
this library lifex um
we're also building up another library
that we call pi facts
and uh this is a library that's
implementing
reduce order models and uh and solving a
certain qualification problems
so this is a research library again and
um
and and this is our frame where we are
developing our model
so this is just a picture to show the
way we split
the different elements you see you can
recognize the ionic model the more
domain equation
the mechanical activation the
circulation model the mechanics
the free dynamics and the perturbation
and when you see a
green arrow it means that we are
coupling those
modes implicitly when actually we go
from left to right
by at the new term level say tm plus one
uh when you see a red arrow it means
that
we are computing some of the models
explicitly some of the core models
explicitly
you also see here these pictures of say
cubic
geometries and they are there to
indicate that we are using different
grids
for the different physical processes
because
the scales are different and and and
more typically we use a
verifying grid for the electrophysiology
um a course grid
for uh the mechanics and the kind of
intermediate grids for the fluid fluid
mechanics
and we're also using a staggered
approach staggered means
that we are using different time steps
because the time scales are different
and again the most demanding is the
electrophysiology
model where we use a time stepper that
is of the order of
say one tenth um the time step that
you're using for the other components
um we have different type of uh
spatial approximation um we go from q1
to q5
these are um
say polynomials of degree
say q5 will be a polynomial degree five
in all variables
uh on on exagra and we use a
backward difference formula of the we
want to three of rangikota method
for time advancing and and for the
treatment of the linear terms we use
both some implicit and implicit terms
we use for the fluid dynamics part we
use
typically q and q1 plus so equal order
interpolation
plus supg stabilization with variational
multiscale
and the largest simulations
for the solvers uh well we use a
linear algebra backhands based on
trilinus and betsy
i use scalable pre-conditioners we use
algebraic multi-grid bddc domain
decomposition
and it is worth a physics-based
preconditional say
and as i was saying before for the
electrophysiology typically i use
10 to the power 7 degrees of freedom
with the delta t
which is of the other tenth of minus
five and this takes typically six hours
on a small c cluster with under cores
um uh electromechanics uh we are a bit
more tolerant in terms of
sorry um relative mechanics so we 24
hours
for the fluid dynamics 24 hours these
are typical
i mean order magnitude right
and uh for the complete uh intellectual
model you estimate
order 100 hours
for a single heartbeat so it's very
demanding so you understand why we need
to to use reduce order models
to solve the forward problem the one
that we have seen before
but even more if you want to use uh
answering quantification because then
we have to solve that so iterate and for
every iteration you have to solve the
the forward model and that and we like
to address both
epistemic uncertainty which is due to
lack of knowledge or experimental error
and
auditory uncertainty which is due to
stochasticity and the variability
between between between individuals for
instance
so um uh here are some examples
uh of course have very little time and
i'll be extremely
quick on that but what i just wanted to
give you an idea of the type of
uh i mean approaches that we're actually
using in terms of
reduce order models and also for
addressing uncertainty
um here we
want to approximate activation patterns
with different type of fiber
distribution and the electrical
conductivity uh conductivities so we
want to explore variability
and and we use the local reduced basis
method
uh what is called the k-means-based so
we are using local
uh reduce basis methods and and and this
is just to give you um
so the knees clustering and this just to
give you an idea of the potential
saving that you can realize with respect
to using uh
the full order model right um
it's the speed up in the order 35 times
uh to achieve a relative error which is
of the order of 10 to the power -2 and
and with the memory storage which is
really i mean you get a
very substantial advantage so with an
error which is between 1
and two percent the speed up is 35 times
uh in this specific case we solve it we
use it also for solving the inverse
problem
and we go from measurement for instance
the electrocardiograms
to try to reconstruct the electric
potential on the epicardium
so is a pde constraint optimization
model
we use ncmc samplings with gamma filters
and use neural networks and again
we are really interested in getting
substantial advantages
um we we use artificial neural network
uh together with physics-based models
and we use that for speeding up the
computation
and for uh devising reduce order mode
let's say
so the idea is always to combine high
fidelity models
with reduced order models in many
different ways here
is uh the purpose is to compute
the model that that produces the
active force at the cell levels
um and uh as you can see of course i had
no time to dis
discard the details but there are
references and
so you can find details in the
references uh
or of course you can contact me i can
send you material but
this is the typical type of uh advantage
that of gain that we have for under time
speed up um for
the fourth generation model and on the
global electromechanical model ten times
the speed up
and the and the hundred hundred uh the
factor of memory saving is order of one
hundred
so it's it's really it's really quite
important
uh this is yet another issue it's
applied to another possible
say um combination of full order model
and reduce order model based on
on deep learning um for the
electrophysiology
and uh here is just a schematic picture
we actually start from full order model
and
we have a convolution uh convolutional
encoder which is major convolution
encoder and the decoder
then then we account for the
parameterization
and use a reduce order model for that
and we end up with a
deep learning reduce order model
for the electrophysiology and here again
you have an idea of the
of the advantage say the full order
money takes two hour
and uh with this uh approximation on the
online phase it takes
less than less than one second um
and those are further
uh combination between uh say
full order and the reduce order models
based on
uh on on the use of artificial neural
network or digital network
and and in this case this is to compute
to solve the inverse problem of the
electrophysiology
um so again here you have a picture of
uh
the potential advantage that you have
and again uh uh
without uh this type of
uh say uh
combination or uh uh of
or boosting of uh computational uh
time by by the use of uh artificial
neural network
of reduce order model uh or deep neural
network
uh it would be i guess
basically impossible to address
real clinical applications i've not had
time to to show them
so we stop here but but to address
clinical applications
uh you really need to end up with
[Music]
those uh reduce order models and uh
and uh this help from uh artificial
neural network
uh in order to be able to account for
the uh variability and and the
uncertainty
and uh and uh i'm allowed to stop here
and thank you very much for uh
for your attention and thank you thank
you i'm glad to take
any question thank you thank you so much
it was a great talk and we will open to
um the audience for any questions they
have
um we do have some questions
uh from unfortunately you're not able to
see the the chat so if you
i'm going to open the microphone i'm
going to read it to you
well i think this the first one is
not a question it's um it's it's uh
some comments from rob blake
and laurence livermore hi dr quatroni
glad you enjoyed the
ldl vm method i have some modifications
that make it
work well for the capillary muscle as
well
oh great so so rob uh if you want to
speak out
uh father yeah i was i was glad to see
my name in the
credits down below um um i was one of
the authors on the um
thing um there's some simple
modifications i can talk to after
you just modify one of the dirichlet
boundaries and you can get um papillary
muscle fibers as well
oh very good thank you or you can send
me
yeah i can send you something by mail
and information yeah
thanks let's be very helpful okay
awesome
um well and the martin uh program
uh she asked about the electro physics
model that looks like a diffusion
reaction
equation but he was wondering about um
the picture of suggesting transport uh
rob was answered has answered that
question
but i i guess um because i'll clear you
you can revisit that
but yeah again let me see if i can
get the model here
this one do you see it
so maybe i can go full screen see if you
can go to the screen
okay
this is a more domain equation so the
question is about the the
reaction diffusion problem that this uh
this govern this equation right so what
is the question exactly sorry
the question is the picture suggests the
transport so
um how how is that
the transport the transport term
the transport looking uh you know
yeah it's here it's almost like
adjection but it's reaction diffusion
and how can that be possible no we don't
have
we don't have transfer no this is not
the transfer uh this one
yeah there isn't no objection times in
equations no there's no definition
no no there is no deficient term uh this
is uh the uh
say time derivative and this is the
elliptic part so this is the divergence
of the
conductivity tensor time the gradient of
u so this is a kind of laplacian say
generalized application
and this is a source term exactly but uh
one of the picture
you showed uh suggested some transport
um
in the simulation right right this one
right right yeah that looks like a
transport term but
roberto
the um internal lasers are generated by
the specific structure of projections
there is no transport
okay uh the next question is
by rob again can you talk a bit more
about
uh what you are doing with a video photo
modeling
well i think you then actually got
answered by the later things i actually
had a general question in the last three
minutes um
where do you see this going um in the
future because you've presented a very
very very complicated um
multi-physics model um or do you plan on
introducing
more multiphysics into it do you plan on
going more reduced order method
or do you plan on going towards clinical
applicability
which direction do you want to move yeah
uh that's a very good question thank you
very much for asking this question
uh this is the question that i'm asking
myself very many times and i
i i i give myself these answers
um i i think i i like to go into
different directions
uh the first one is just the direction
of bringing more knowledge
into the subject if possible of course
meaning that
i like to have a basic
um integrated heart model that is
capable to describe the function
of the old heart in all its components
and and they try to convey this message
by
showing you all these i mean different
chord models
and they were a couple together of
course this is uh
this has no limit in the sense that you
can improve the model
uh every time i mean
as far as you better understand biology
and physiology
then you can improve your model but
already this model
is i think good enough to address
uh clinical issues and this is the
second part
so when you address clinical clinical uh
questions uh we will never use almost
never use the
the full model that that's too much
this is to reach if you want right and
we try to
specify uh to use sub components of the
model to address specific questions
for instance this is an example to
address arrhythmias
basically the fluid dynamics in the
ventricles are irrelevant almost
irrelevant
uh they might be relevant in the atrium
because um
of the auricula where you have
recirculation but
let me say generally speaking when you
address a problem of clinical relevance
we try to understand what is important
to what is less important
and in the overall model with this
regard we drop what is not
so important so these allow us to go
into the reduce order model
part when we isolate
the components that are useful to this
specific application
then there we try to take advantage of
reduce order models
in particular to address uncertainty so
um
somehow we scale down the complexity
when we address clinical applications
because otherwise
uh that would be simply to to too
demanding
and that this is the same also for i
mean
through dynamics when for instance in
this case where there's a problem that
has to see with the myosectomy and uh
and in this case the electrical field is
not playing it all
so you you will account for uh
the meccano fluid part and disregard the
rest
so there is a component which is let me
say
uh of academic interest we try to
improve the knowledge in the field and i
want my model to be
as inclusive as possible and and and
and this might be extremely expensive
computationally speaking but i want to
be able to provide
pictures simulations quantitative
information that would be
otherwise impossible to have with the
standard
imaging tools that we have nowadays so
this is one
goal and the other goal is go into more
specific questions
from the clinical side and for that i
really have to
uh lean up my model to to the limit
and uh to to limit it to the most
important component
and to use very extensively use order
models and
and say deep learning or artificial
neural network in order to provide
solutions in a shorter time by setting
compromise in terms of
accuracy
thank you thank you so much um i i do
have
one question um you mentioned the pde or
where
on the deep learning models um
i i'm guessing you have already applied
such
methods yes in your project and if you
can
um give give us some more details about
it well
this is one where we really combine uh
full order model with uh
with uh basically to to compute the
snapshots
right and then and then we and then you
we train
the network with this uh snapshot but
but this is another one this is another
example where you are actually
embed um the information from the
physics
from the models into into the neural
network this is
they are to solve an inverse problem as
you see we start from data and those are
on the left hand side those are the ecg
maps and we use a neural network
to end up with a model
and then we use
the pde model which is
the one that combines the
electrophysiology in the myocardium
together with
the laplace equation in the torso
we use this model to uh basically
set up the the the the cost function
and uh and and and to to to to train our
network
and then we return the electrocardiogram
uh signal uh
with with this cell basically so uh
what we try to do here is to solve the
full world that inverse problem
electrophysiology
with uh uh is a kind of physics
information network
uh i think the name that was given uh in
the first paper
uh is uh uh uh is is not exactly the
same but it's
basically about the same i mean we
really try to take advantage of uh
the physical models uh in order to
uh uh to to to set up to realize
uh an artificial neural network model
today
right um i i totally agree that we need
to
incorporate some the first principle
into the the deep learning
models we have um i i do think that
a lot of people is going to do more
research on those
i think according to my to our
recent experience uh this is really one
way to go
we really see that in in several like
many problems really
i mean if you set a compromise in terms
of accuracy
uh it's always a matter of trade-off
between computational time and
accuracy right when you when you deal
with such complex models
so if you really play with this in a in
a suitable way
and you set up the accuracy that is
mandatory at the clinical level
and and you want to fulfill that
accuracy and then we try to be as
efficient as possible then combining uh
a physics-based with uh with the
data-driven
models it's certainly i'm not saying
is the only way but totally it gives us
a very
important advantage right totally agree
um
i just wanted to add as well i have some
unpublished stuff we have a giant
database of simulations and
reconstructed
um simulations and we have some stuff
that shows that given
just an ecg we can actually
reconstruct some like an equivalent of
kind of an iconal
um distribution of what's happening
everywhere inside the heart
okay so like just not even having to put
any models in just go straight from
ecg's
to what's happening inside the heart
all right should you be doing it a
million simulations okay
okay and using the kernel model no no
um equivalent
okay okay
okay we we do have one more question
from long
chant he said thank you for the
talk can you elaborate more about
uncertainties
for example you have talked about
epistemic and
earlier toric uncertainties which is
more interesting in medical practice
well um i think that what is
important here is well first of all in
medical practice
you have uncertainties everywhere right
i mean uh
you have uncertainty from uh um
the data characterizing the patient
patient itself
ourselves say the individual um
so the data that characterizes the shape
that they because
of course you have you have errors in
imaging acquisition you have very lack
of information about the fibers for
instant fiber distribution
you have very lack of information about
the mechanical characteristics
of the tissue the mechanical tissue
you have uncertainty on the
boundary condition if you have isolated
systems
and those are initial conditions how do
you how do you say
start your uh your simulator so you
don't have
initial data you're very far from the
beauty of the pdes where you
are given a boundary condition and the
initial condition the forcing term
and the and the material coefficient you
are very far from here
from there so those are very important
uh
those are very important uncertainty
uncertain elements that you have to play
with
and and one possibility is to use those
uncertain elements and try to introduce
probability space you represent them in
a
of course in a probability space and we
try
to see the way your forward model
propagates these uncertainties onto the
desired solution the output this is one
way
the other way is when you start from
measurements and you want to reconstruct
uh in an uncertain way for instance the
coefficient
of the fiber distribution again in a
probability space
not in a deterministic way so those are
two elements
and and then you have the
um inter-patient
uncertainty uh you you know that
we are all uh each of us different and
uh
i mean everyone else um and uh
and what what is the dream here the
dream is that
uh i mean one possible dream is to have
a
atlas of people of different shapes of
art for instance
and then trying to to move
from when you have a newcomer to try to
exploit
the previously available information and
try to
not extrapolate but to produce a result
on the basis of the previous computer
results
in a again in a certain way so you have
intra patience and interpersonal
uncertainty and we like to
eventually address with all these cases
of course
it's a kind of gigantic effort but we
so far we have some examples some
instances
of applications where you can i mean
those are really proof of concept you
really want to see that
to prove that you can set up a
mathematical
paradigm say mathematical setting that
in principle allow you to treat with all
those uncertainties but
again the issue of producing results
within a tolerable accuracy
with acceptable computational time is
really a big issue it's going to be
challenging
so it's a proof of concept basically
okay
we we have a one more question uh from
markin
uh did you use any lds model uh
yes this is for the uh uh this is for
the fluid dynamics
we use a dynamic leds model uh we are
actually using a q and q one and see if
we can restore it but there is no detail
here in this presentation
yeah we have navistox equations in the
ventricles and in the atria
we use q1q1 q1 for the velocity field
and through upper pressure
so uh bilinear or trilinear element
actually because we are in
3d trilinear elements for velocity and
pressure
then we have supg stabilization uh which
means that you are acting you are adding
ratios
to the continuity equation to the
momentum equation
and then we use les in a variational
multi-scale framework
is a dynamically yes so this is pretty
much on the
on the line of what uh say tom use and
uh
all his schools say he's been doing in
the past
20 years uh for um for for separating
the scales
in in a problem which is uh and not
turbulent because this problem is not
actually turbulent
i mean the fluid dynamics in the
ventricles is not
does not uh at least in a in healthy
patients
uh that that does not
heal the turbulent flow but is a kind of
permanent transition towards turbulence
um because you know there's not enough
space
and not enough time to develop a full
develop to to to produce a full
developed turbulence
so we have a transition to turbulence uh
and and that's why we are using actual
larger dissipation
let's say turmeric models thank you
thank you
um i do not see any more questions
well that doesn't mean you cannot ask
questions if you have questions i'll
unmute yourself and
ask questions you're welcome to do so
well if now let's thank our today's
speaker
uh professor alteocaroni thank you so
much
thank you and i thank everybody thank
you
my talk okay thank you great great uh
hosting uh
you today um just for the uh
the announcements uh i think i believe i
have to check but i do believe that we
have another ddps seminar
um next week so please stay tuned
and until then uh stay safe and see you
next time okay bye bye have a good day